taper dessus tu as valeur
on va vous faire repasser le bac le gars
qu'on va pas être déçu des résultats tu
l'as pas lui bah moi non plus tu l'as vu
toi ton bac c'est oui ou non de la
caméra oui la vue il n'a eu voilà
heureusement on a quelqu'un avec nous
qui lui a fait de grandes études
j'aime le regarder dormir tout de suite
comme ça on s'en fait
la bouche ample
je
bonjour à tous rencontres de cinéma vous
donne rendez vous aujourd'hui dans une
classe de collège
on aura tout vu à l'occasion d'un
premier long métrage le nouveau et
interviews dans un instant du
réalisateur rudi rosenberg de max
boublil et des trois jeunes interprètes
je crois pas mieux j'ai tout donné
bonjour à tous ce qui n'aide pas là
c'est un vrai plaisir de vous recevoir
je me concentre bonjour ça c'est bon
j'ai l'émission du bon on y va il arrive
propos alors ce contenu je crois que au
milieu où est ce qu'on met rudy
ingénieurs sont ingénieurs sont est ce
que tu peux faire un petit somme le
micro raconte ta vie raconte que tu veux
le chili coraux
et voilà et rudy nioro et loach il est
petit il est là max blue blue
pas de trucs raciste pas de pédophilie
pas d'autre nom du show business
l'avenir de notre pays
ces bons arguments mais je vous préviens
radio on allait voir des adhérents de la
coupe carnac ou quoi d'accord de cheveux
ou la combine les faire couper c'est
pour ça que joue le retard nous le
retard est venu appuyer gfg papier comme
ie faire voilà mieux merci à tous les
cinq d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
ça vous connaît les moments de conneries
de blagues et de l'aide aux foyers
ouais je professionnel c'est vrai érudit
vous a demandé justement de de les
travailler ces conneries ses blagues
donc vous êtes obligé de vous freiner
une claque par tonne par le bien c'est
le plus sage de tous moi je vois ça
ouais par rapport à 2000 a envie de me
tuer trois minutes
sur les tournages
généralement les enfants c'est souvent
des petits comédiens en herbe qui sont
déjà très bons rp qui vont voir les
vedettes qui leur demandent des numéros
et et eux ils en ont à et nature
et c'est pas des petits singes savants
et ça c'est très agréable
ces singes tout court il est trouve
drôle nous font rire
ils sont gros ils sont ils sont
irrespectueux et on était tous les deux
comme ça ta gueule on était comme ça
alors âgées c'est ça qu'il faut un visa
avec ces petits bouts de chou dont
j'étais par an c'est une blague
ils sont légers ils vont porter les gens
ils vont dormir briscoe pas de dormir
d'abord parce que le film est court il
fait primer 10h20
non mais c'est vrai qu'à y être et il ya
beaucoup de rythme
merci à tous les sens merci bonjour
excusez nous
c